I'm a new rife user. I have a daily overnight program and also three shorter daytime programs.
Which should I run if I have time during the day? Can I tell how long the day programs are?
So the daytime programs, they're not in order or anything. Your overnight programs aren't
in any order whatsoever either. Does it make a difference if, oh,
shoot today's Wednesday and I realized I ran Thursday's program. So what? Then just run Wednesdays
tomorrow or just run Thursdays again tomorrow. It doesn't make any difference.
Oh, which day program should I run? It doesn't make any difference. So just start with the first one.
They can be, you know, I don't remember on everybody's program how long they are, but as soon as you
open up that program and hit run, you'll see the countdown timer. So you'll see how long the
program is. So what if it's two hours and I only have an hour? Just run it for an hour then.
You know, what if it's, you know, what if I only have 15 minutes? Just run it for 15 minutes then
and turn off if you have to get up and go do something and you're not coming back. There's nothing
wrong with that. There's no wrong way to do it. There's no wrong, there's no wrong way to run any
of your programs. So don't, don't get hung up on thinking you have to do those things
right. The wrong way to do it is to not do it. So that's the wrong way to do it. So you just want to
run those programs. When I was in the thick of my cancer, I was running literally, I've said this
dozens of times. I'd get home and sit in my chair. I had the right right there and I turned it
on and I was running my program. If I got up to go eat or got up to go do something, I just let it
run and I came back and sit down. Sometimes it was five minutes later. Sometimes it was an hour later.
It was just running my whole overnight program. So I ran my overnight program. So as I got home and
when I was ready to go to bed, I turned it off and turned it back on and ran my overnight program
all night long. And then when I went to work, I was running the rife all day at work. Now,
I wasn't always sitting at my desk, but when I was sitting at my desk, I was getting the frequencies,
but then I'd get up and go help people and go do things and I came back and sat at my desk and I was
running the rife program all day long. So I was getting as much rife time as possible. But
you know, again, I was in a situation where there wasn't any other hope for me with my cancer.
So I just, I had to hit this as hard as I possibly could. So I just think the more rife time you get
the better. Within reason, I don't want you to not live your life because you have to do the rife.
I want, you know, if you have to go play with the grandkids, go be with the grandkids. But, you know,
you want to, well, you're sitting and doing nothing, reading a book or so either watching TV or
rather be running the rife set up your house that you can do that. And that's there's no wrong way
to do it if you're doing it if you're just running the programs.